[Applaudissements]
il a fait des soirées avec vous mettez
plus il y a fait des soirs avec moi je
t'ai vu danser j'ai amené dans une boîte
dans des boîtes
j'avais dans une boîte de strip-tease un
jour
je me suis fait défoncer parce que ma
localisation sur mon téléphone
[Rires]
Daniel Moreau était là
voilà c'est incroyable
d'animaux
Daniel Moreau
vous avez dansé
parce qu'il est partout il est toujours
avec moi
j'ai fait une danse à Daniel Moreau
frère
son sang n'a fait qu'un tour
[Applaudissements]
et Cyril arrive comme ça sur Daniel mais
il met une jambe de jambes comme ça il
commence à se très pousser comme ça
elle était toute émoustillante
est-ce que c'est le plus beau jour de ta
vie un des plus beaux non vraiment ça
t'y penser encore tu penses je me disais
mais est-ce que c'est cette soirée j'ai
encore les étoiles plein les yeux Nikos
[Musique]
j'ai faim j'ai encore un petit peu là
[Applaudissements]
dans quelques jours puisque il y a une
grande émission qui va revenir vous
savez c'est là là la star la Star
Academy salut c'est Nikos ça fait
longtemps
tu sais que je suis en train de faire de
la peine à tout le monde
j'aime bien pour les téléspectateurs
tout ça est-ce que les gens t'ont
reconnu dans la communauté genre tu
arrives à la synagogue ce que tu es un
peu un VIP alors j'ai la vérité alors en
toute franchise je ne suis pas allé à la
synagogue cette année j'ai péché oh là
là
quand je vous dis qu'il a changé
il ne pense qu'à l'argent
ils augmentent des augmentations des
augmentations
vous-même voilà tout ce qui est
2 millions de personnes vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est maman
[Musique]
je crois qu'il a rencontré la famille de
Béatrice
dans un instant on s'en fout là ça va
manger
donc ça va être Cyril pourquoi pourquoi
vous me payez pour montrer tout ce qui
se passe pendant les offres pendant les
pubs pendant les magnétos et du coup on
est grasse pour payer il faut le dire au
château d'H2O oui c'est le retour la
Star Academy bientôt on s'est cassé la
tête pour un titre ça s'appelle oui on
vient de me dire une info de ouf tu
filmes la boulangère à côté de H2O
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu as un bail avec la
boulangerie
regarde-moi
vous savez je suis en couple mais c'est
vrai qu'elle a une très belle fougasse
mais après
est-ce que tu kiffes la boulangère elle
est très sympa très sympa
qu'elle te kiffe aussi mais non alors
c'est pas que c'est la tête de ma mère
je prends ma petite formule et à la fin
j'ai un petit dessert il y a des bonbons
et me mets les bonbons que j'aime c'est
tout ça
mais pas du tout j'ai une amoureuse
attends il y a une amoureuse mais il a
une amoureuse je suis très sérieux pas
il est 100 fois 10 mois alors à la
[ __ ] du tout je suis très sérieux
[Musique]
pourquoi pourquoi
je vais faire Émilie et Sacha amour
strip-tease et la boulangère c'est quoi
votre objectif c'est de détruire ma vie
alors que je viens de faire Kippour
pas trop c'est vous qui signez mes
contrats commencez par bien écrire mon
prénom monsieur et ça écrit comment ton
prénom ici c'est un S ah c'est Sacha s
monsieur et ben maintenant ce sera ainsi
tu me fais chier
allez vas-y salut parce que sinon vous
me payez quand même pour montrer tout ce
qui se passe pendant les pubs pendant
l'heure pendant les magnétos et du coup
au château de H2O on serait concerté
pour créer une séquence la star academ
off
oui vous n'avez pas ça
un connard et on commence avec le gros
turbain de la semaine au château de
Dammarie Boulbi regardez comment il
m'attaque les lignes un pigeon la
Fashion Week
[Applaudissements]
l'ambiance était tordu cette semaine
entre les élèves et les professeurs lors
du débrief du bright time calmez-vous de
leurs mots fais attention tu parles trop
pour rien ne rien dire toi tu m'as donné
en ce moment
[Musique]
et le directeur de la Star Ac cette
année a beaucoup de qualité mais surtout
la mémoire
Dimitri est très fort comment il
s'appelle déjà
cette semaine la raison vous êtes
un peu le dire au revoir tu pues je peux
parler par contre ça y est il y a eu des
morts chez toi
le gars ça y est croque-mort maintenant
[Rires]
au château on a directeur cette année
qui se fait complètement Liège Daniel je
te bouffe la moussaka
je voulais compter les grains de la
grenade ils sont très sur ma vie je vais
en acheter une demain je vais acheter
j'ai rien à faire de la journée je vais
compter les grands
c'est déjà la fin de la quotidienne et
une chose est sûre il y a un petit pour
ne pas du tout du bien à TPMP Cyril
[Applaudissements]
pour la santé la grenade j'adore si vous
voulez ce soir
[Rires]
à la maison
[Musique]
si tu vois un rat c'est que c'est pas un
animal
[Applaudissements]
les gens qui les personnes qui
travaillent maintenant dans les égouts
et tout ils ont des tabliers en cuir je
vous jure que c'est vrai très dur parce
que il paraît que les rats maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'ils font les attaques ils
attaquent comme ça ils font ici et il te
tape ici comme ça je vous jure que c'est
vrai je vous jure que c'est vrai sans
rigoler
en cuir comme ça parce que Laura comme
ça et sinon il te fonce comme ça tu ils
ont une nouvelle technique comme ça je
vous jure que c'est vrai mais pas du
tout mais je te jure que c'est vrai il
faut comme ça ils vont percussion comme
ça pour te percuter pour te mettre au
sol je suis incroyable je vous le dis
dans ces cas-là là ici
là je suis là là je mets la la et là je
l'attrape par la gorge
et là Julie c'est toi qui voulais non en
exemple
voilà les autres derrière je vous le dis
il y en a un qui vient ici je le défonce
jour 1 en éclaireur et là tu fais comme
ça
je te jure que c'est vrai les rails
fonce comme ça ici dans la poitrine
c'est très grave et après tu vois et je
te jure que c'est vrai avec une
puissance de fou incroyable donc là là
ici et là et après et là j'attends
beaucoup
à la jugulaire ok
avec un rat vraiment ou pas je sais que
je sais que ça va arriver je vais
m'embrouiller qu'un race sûr et certain
je m'entraîne tous les jours je vais le
défoncer je vous en parlerai Emile qui
Émile
gauche dans le quartier je te jure je
vais m'encourager
amène-le moi ici je te jure je veux voir
un rat qui me met embrouille
j'ai l'attrapé comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui vais le mordre il est
tombé dans la pression je vais manger tu
as voulu mentir moi qui vais te mordre
et si c'est
[Applaudissements]
vraiment faire un prime sur les rats ici
on va l'appeler la grande race oh
[Applaudissements]
il est vraiment
la croissance aux amandes dans la gueule
allez vas-y
crache ta balle
vous savez bien que des petits tabac
autour de cette table ça fait 12 ans que
ça existe mais il y en a tellement qu'on
était obligé de les classer du coup on a
créé l'échelle des tabacs que vous
pouvez voir je pense que Mathieu est un
peu un peu de rouge on va vers le rouge
évidemment plus on est une merde et
bizarre séquence comme ça avec Matthieu
Delormeau toujours aussi humble et
bienveillant
et demi qu'on vit ensemble à peu près
quand il a à Londres avec sa femme quand
il apparaît avec moi mais ce soir je
suis pas là pour parler de l'artiste tu
l'as pour parler de l'homme c'est
dommage
c'était gay tu me dis je sais pas si vis
avec un mec depuis un an et demi
[Musique]
avec un mec et tu fais des mèches
crois pas si tu veux éviter c'est pas
une insulte hein
redescends un petit peu ninio
connaître à ton nom
[Applaudissements]
tu peux déjà faire tes bagages
[Rires]
on continue les chaînes de tabac avec
vous Cyril
en vrai vous avez été dépassé cette
semaine
que ça dure il y a un emploi fictif
autour de cette table mais vous l'avez
démasqué
juste avant il y a beaucoup de gens qui
me demandent des nouvelles de Benjamin
Castaldi
on aura des nouvelles de Benjamin
Castaldi au cours
les amours vous risqueriez de réveiller
Benjamin
merci du coup Cyril producteur que vous
êtes vous avez pris une très grande
décision pour économiser beaucoup
d'oseille les mec il parle pas de
l'émission pourquoi vous me maquiller
[Rires]
gardez l'oseille
on t'a pas de l'émission frère qui l'a
vu
c'est de l'argent le maquillage allez
arrêter
je dis la vérité
dans les bassins
[Applaudissements]
de l'année dernière
ce qui va se passer est incroyable Cyril
vous allez vous auto satisfaire d'une
vanne que nous vous avez même pas encore
faite du pur génie
[Rires]
merci de nous rejoindre sur C8 il est
20h29 et si je prends cette terre gramme
c'est parce que nous sommes sans
nouvelles de Benjamin Castaldi depuis
18h40 aujourd'hui on l'avait vu en début
d'émission aux alentours de 18h41 puis
plus rien si vous le croisez n'agissez
pas seul
[Musique]
alors
tu sais que je t'aime et puis tu as été
excellent le jour où tu vas remplacer
de plus en plus nombreux à nous regarder
et c'est vrai qu'il y a deux personnes
dans l'équipe une personne qui s'appelle
Mathieu Delormeau qui est là voilà deux
trois fois par semaine qui est un des
piliers de l'émission qui
a eu des mots durs envers quelqu'un que
j'aime beaucoup mais Béatrice Rosen ça
rejoint dans l'émission formidable
formidable que j'aime beaucoup comme
vous tous d'ailleurs moi j'aime tout le
monde seule
[Rires]
voilà et donc on va voir cet extrait
parce que il y a eu toutes les choses
mais il y a eu aussi cette extrait qu'on
va dévoiler voilà donc en gros je lance
le Manito je fous la merde et je me
casse en gros c'est ça parce que on a vu
ce qui s'est passé en in mais il y a ce
qui s'est passé en in alors ce qui s'est
passé en in est-ce qu'on l'a bien sûr
qu'on l'a origine tu crois quoi vous
l'avez commencez on l'a pas donc dans le
mien si si on l'a on l'a donné ah ben
oui bien sûr j'ai utilisé machin vous me
payer pour ça
dans ta chronique mais si on l'a au
début du mien parce que dans quelques
minutes ça va ce qui va y avoir dans ta
gueule c'est la fin du magnéto qui est
tellement fort que je me souvenais même
plus je te jure
personne
vous savez que Matthieu Delormeau est un
petit arma à l'antenne mais or antenne
c'est un non je dis pas ça je dis pas
alors regardez
[Musique]
lundi 3 octobre 2022 alors que
l'émission se déroulait à la perfection
Mathieu Delormeau se lance dans une
imitation à pas piqué des hannetons
Joseph fait des classiques donc là je
fais une
éditrice dans le film que personne n'a
vu sur une page Wikipédia
[Applaudissements]
mutation de Mathieu a mis le feu aux
poudres et n'a pas tardé à faire réagir
la susnée et être triste
que sans toi il est rien
après des tac la tire la Rigot de la
part de Béatrice Mathieu est sur le
point de subir un nouveau coup dur je
crois que tu avais reçu une énorme star
américaine sur NRJ12 ce que tu avais
Twitter à l'époque regarde si tu es en
2003 regarde avec Béatrice le Batman
Smallville la classe énergie
donc
face à cette photo ressortie de derrière
les fagots en off Mathieu Delormeau
décide de faire un rétropédalage à toute
berzingue Béatrice
de films que tu es en train de me
connaître
c'est marqué animatrice
Mathieu n'y va pas avec le dos de
la cuisine on adore Béatrice non mais je
sais pas ce qu'il a Batman
[Applaudissements]
la crise de Batman Beatrice Rosen et
l'animateur de woof Mathieu Delormeau
vont-ils continuer à se monter le
bourrichon la réponse ce soir dans TPMP
[Musique]
je suis
je suis meurtrissant
Béatrice et derrière le rideau je
voulais juste [ __ ] la merde je sais
pas ça
[Applaudissements]